Ángela partido que nos deja algo que
puede ser histórico Francia los
campeones del mundo vencieron a
Marruecos en semifinales y van a buscar
hacer lo que no hace ninguna selección
desde 1962 cuando Brasil consiguió
retener su corona un partido este que se
disputó aquí en el estadio albed en el
que Este triunfo se encaminó muy pronto
para el combinado galo con un gol al
minuto 5 para Teo Hernández esto puso al
combinado de Marruecos en una situación
que no habían vivido en esta copa mundo
estar con el marcador en contra algo que
los obligó a romper esa férrea defensa
ese Ferrer bloque y así era yo los que
tenían que buscar el partido además de
las cosas no le salieron bien por parte
de las lesiones ayer uno de sus defensas
estrellas se lesionó del calentamiento y
no pudo ser inicialista además cuando
apenas transcurría una media hora del
partido sáinz otro hombre clave de la
saga también tuvo que abandonar el campo
y es que pese a que lo niega su
seleccionador wallet regraga y la fatiga
se hizo sentir en los Leones del Atlas
hizo sentir jugadores como rabat
con Francia no jugaron radio y tampoco
jugó upa americano entraron fofanite en
su reemplazo una frase que para la
segunda parte le cedió la pelota a
Marruecos que se volcó por completo el
ataque y fue en este juego en el que
Francia esperaba con salidas en las
bandas cuando llegó el premio hace dos a
cero que lo hizo Colo Colo maní el uno
de los últimos convocados de esta
selección de Francia y lo hizo en la
primera pelota que tocó dos a cero para
Francia la selección de Francia que
contó con Ochoa espectacular en el
centro del campo los dirigidos por
Francia que va a jugar su cuarta final
de copa mundo lo hicieron en 1998 lo
hicieron en 2006 lo hicieron en Rusia
2018 y aquí se van a medir a la
Argentina de Lionel Messi de nuevo como
ocurrió en 1998 una final contra un
rival sudamericano además rival inédita
en la copa mundo